all right now we'll have full reaction
to president Trump's speech supporting
Dr Oz a full-throated endorsement uh
tonight it's been an amazing race to
watch primary uh to watch two things
that come to mind right off the top of
my head do you think Joe Biden could do
a rally like that I think it's
impossible and I doubt many people would
even uh show up what's been amazing
about this race is an and I support Dr
Osmond very upfront and open because
he's an America First conservative he
believes in lower taxes less bureaucracy
he believes in energy Independence look
at the state of Pennsylvania we have 200
plus years of natural gas under our feet
we could be supplying our NATO allies or
Western European allies Dr Oz has faced
tens of millions of dollars from
establishment hacks turning him into
somebody unrecognizable he supports
secure borders energy Independence he
supports Law and Order he supports uh
school choice he supports
constitutionalists on the bench he is a
believer in peace through strength and
he believes in free and fair trade I
know because I've known him when I
endorsed Donald Trump very early on
there were a lot of people that attacked
me and said oh Hannity what about Donald
Trump he was once pro-life pro-choice he
once donated Democrats even the clintons
and he did this I said yeah that was so
you can basically keep building
buildings in New York and he knew the
system and he played the system because
that was the only way he could get his
workers to be able to work and admitted
it was ridiculous
um Dr Oz is a America First make America
great again save America conservative
and now the president with a 55-0 record
endorsements uh in a row uh this is
going to be interesting to see the
impact we'll have full coverage of the
president in his rally but I want to
turn our attention back to the White
House first where Joe Biden has had a
rough couple of days take a look you
decide
thank God you're on our team yes sir
thank you appreciate it
where am I heading realize how many
lives
you really lose
50 times 48 times
there he is he's educating people in the
back there you go
he's over here how can you miss her well
I I tell you what Naomi how are you
that's my granddaughter my oldest our
oldest granddaughter
and her fiance and I can't see and Peter
and Peter
obviously Joe is not doing well and
during one semi-lucid moment Biden
openly reminisced about the good old
days when he ate lunch with
segregationists you can't make this up
take a look
we've always used to fight like hell and
uh even back in the old days when we had
real segregations like Eastland and
Thurman and all those guys but at least
we end up eating lunch together
things have changed we got to bring it
back
good old days you can have lunch with
segregationists wow that's the same guy
that uh partnered oh that's right with a
former klansman Robert Byrd to stop the
integration of public schools uh he
didn't want public schools to become
racial jungles that was his words every
week he gets worse and worse make no
mistake Joe is not in charge he barely
knows that tonight is Friday what day of
the week it is and while he daughters
along radical socialists have taken
control of the democratic party and for
the past year they have been steering
this country off a cliff faster than
even I anticipated I told you it would
be bad Live Free or Die America in the
world on the brink now ahead of the
midterms in order to distract from their
many failures Liberals are now
attempting to Gin up Mass hysteria after
someone leaked Justice alito's draft
opinion that could soon overturn Roe v
Wade and the Casey rulings now of course
a bro is overturned in spite of all the
hyperbole out there lying out there
propaganda misinformation out there
abortion in America will still be legal
in the U.S and will be regulated by
State legislatures this is what we've
said for a long time if you're a
conservative you believe in the
Constitution uh they made up a right not
enumerated in the Constitution well
that's supposed to then go to the states
that's called the 10th Amendment now
according to prominent Democrats the
world is ending the sky is falling our
country will never be the same take a
look
this opinion is dark it is incredibly
dangerous and it is not just about a
woman's right to choose it is about much
more than that any American says look
I'm not a woman this doesn't affect me
I'm not black that doesn't affect me I'm
not gay that doesn't affect me once you
allow this kind of extreme power to take
hold you have no idea who they will come
for next this is a radical right-wing
runaway Republican sanction assault by
this supreme court on our freedom on our
constitution we don't have a long
history of protecting equal marriage we
don't have a long history of protecting
interracial marriage we don't have a
long history of protecting access to
contraception all of those things that
we have now counted on and said that's
the America we are
could potentially under Justice alito's
own analysis go out by the way now
what's their plan oh let's go back to
court packing we'll try that none of
what they're saying is true not one word
uh but while Democrats feign their
outrage their radical followers are
taken to the streets some are attempting
to harass Supreme Court Justices at
their homes activists posting a map
online doxing their personal addresses
putting out the personal addresses of
Supreme Court Justices others are
outside the Supreme Court building where
law enforcement now has erected a large
wall and concrete barriers to protect
the building and those uh working inside
from far left rioters meanwhile one
left-wing group is now planning to
Target pro-life Catholic churches on
Mother's day and just this week a church
in Denver was already vandalized with
the pro-abortion graffiti so let me be
clear on this program we condemn all
political violence all intimidation
we've got to include we've got to
protect every single elected official
every judge that serves everybody that
works in government needs to be
protected and frankly every American uh
deserves Law and Order and Safety and
Security because without which you
cannot pursue happiness can you and
that's the problem with defund dismantle
no bail laws that the Democrats have
supported now that's not the case with
the Democrats they are willing to
contend violence when it helps them only
politically in fact almost no one in the
Democratic party is even willing to
condemn the doxing giving out the
addresses and the harassment of U.S
Supreme Court Justices why their silence
is deafening just like in the summer of
2020 what 574 riots we had dozens of
dead Americans thousands of injured
police officers billions in property
damage where's that committee looking
into those riots where are those
prosecutions many Democrats even
handling the the Supreme Court leaker as
a hero it's almost as if they want this
these justices to face intimidation and
of course Democrats really only care
about power and this year there is no
way they can run on their record it's so
atrocious so now buckle up because we're
about to face a steady stream of
Hysteria now for the next six months hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else